hey you know that the las vegas trip is
just over three miles long sometimes
tourists find out the hard way it's a
pretty long walk but there's an
easier way to make that trip our bianca
holman live with the latest on the
re-opening of the monorail
bianca hey nate yes
we are the first to ride in 15 months
yes right here live local now eight news
now the first and we want to thank you
thanks saying a special thanks to laurie
nelson crowd for welcoming us
tell us who don't know the history of
the monorail
well the story began back in 1995 with
two trains that were from walt disney
and they were used to shuttle guests
between valleys and mgm
and then in 2004 the system expanded to
what it is today
and it goes it's almost a four mile
track from the sahara down to the mgm
with seven
stops and in the past year the lvcva
took ownership of the monorail
because it's an important transportation
system to move our visitors around the
destination
definitely the convention visitors
people headed down us locals down to the
las vegas strip
tell us about ticketing for those who
don't know well let's start with locals
first
you can go for as little as a dollar a
ride there's a twenty pack
pass for twenty dollars but a single
ride is as
value oriented as five dollars and you
can do a one day two day or three day
pass if you're here in town
starting at thirteen dollars so very
cost efficient
a lot of convenience you can use if you
buy a pass you can get on and off as
much as you want throughout the day so
really easy this is so great because
it's right here at the holiday weekend
memorial day weekend we've got
conventions coming up
you've got lots of tourists and people
coming even the legends concert like
hector was saying lots of shows so this
is going to be so key as we reopen las
vegas and
again tell us how this is very green it
helps our environment
absolutely these we are an
all-electric system and zero emissions
from these trains which is really
important and
memorial day on our leisure visitations
really kicking in and on june 8th we
welcome our first major
trade show back with world of concrete
so our visitors are starting to return
there's pent-up demand
and we're thrilled the monorail will be
able to service our visitors now
incredible i know you all served
millions of people every single year
and do tell us there are some covert
restrictions still with public
transportation right
right so we're still asking for
our visitors to wear masks on the system
and
you know we're going to continue
respecting and honoring those guidelines
all right wonderful so again the we are
the first riders
you know but you can come and ride at 7
a.m
it starts today so another great sign
that las vegas we're back to work we're
reopening
and again great things happening all
summer long i'm going to send it back to
you guys
in the studio